[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
it's been three long long long weeks but
finally
we are back to break down all the map
changes in the world of fortnite battle
royale
to keep this three-year-old series going
please think about using code adamaru
over halloween so fortnite chapter two
season four week eight
man time flies let's do this
i loaded up fortnite with excitement
which was then trebled by this
penny she's got a new variant a
halloween cat slash
pumpkin skin so in honor of this
legendary update
i will don this skin today and because
it's the spooky time of year it's time
to crack out el fisto again
the brofist of horror okay i'm totally
ready now let's go
so many places to begin but the one
which i feel is the most important this
season
is the bromance eight weeks ago now
following the fall of midas
two henchmen were left in pieces one for
ghost
and one opting for shadow on week three
the two had a tense face-off in a cafe
in the middle of nowhere
and somehow put their differences aside
to form a bond
expressed through dance two weeks later
these bros were so committed to that
bromance they moved into the hotel at
lazy lake
to hold their own pool parties have
dance competitions
and they even took out wolverine and now
in game the henchmen have moved over to
the hydro dam still together
so i stalked the two and this is what
they do here's their story
the two can be found primarily here
they've made the old turbine slash
museum into a home
the shadow dude enjoys watching tv which
looks fantastic and the ghost guy is
checking out their new gaff
suddenly he spots another place to live
and calls his brother from another
mother
to come check it out he agrees and then
slowly
and i mean slowly these guys walk so
slow they get to the dam
in a touching moment they take in the
sights right in the fields this is so
touching
hang on i have an idea yeah sorry
pretend i didn't do that back back to
the story they finally make it to the
second building and ghost
doesn't like it anti-climax are what so
they walk all the way back home
and that's it they simply repeat these
actions over and over again
any idea where they could be going next
oh that reminds me i asked you to name
these bros last time
and we have a winning set of names they
will now be forever called
bill and ted breathtaking names
if you don't know who bill and ted are
check in the comments i'm sure you'll be
told by a person
wiser than me whilst looking for a
future spot for the two henchmen i
checked back on their old homes
in retail the store has not been updated
this year it usually becomes a spooky
store
more on that very soon but over at the
authority
there is something you need to see
inside the top layer where the shadow
henchmen once lived
you know with his shrine to brutus
there's a new item here now
midas's golden chair has returned
this chair has been around for a few
seasons now it was midas
favorite chair in the meeting room
before it was stolen
transported across a lake and put in
someone's house
but it was so heavy that it broke
through the floor
then we started moved into storage
before vanishing forever
well at least we thought it was forever
because now it's back
and it's waiting please hit me with your
predictions now
there are a handful of chairs up here
but three in a row maybe midas
and bill and ted or it could be for the
rightful king to return
brutus r.i.p forever in our hearts
find out what happens next in the next
update
so i mentioned the usual update to the
map for halloween
and it has begun if you look around the
map right now the occasional house is
dressed up
with spooky llamas and spiders there's
even a trailer this year that's got
involved with the festivities and over
the next few weeks the whole
neighborhood usually gets on board and
gets in the spooky vibes
but where are they getting their
decorations this year
i know you've already guessed it the new
superstar over at holly hedges
is now confirmed to be a halloween star
named heibu
three weeks ago when the building was
erected we all guessed it would be for
halloween on christmas
and we were right pat yourself on the
back those that guessed it
inside it is uh far from opening day
officially
but it does now have a set of tills a
basic kitchen
and a few desks and of course that sign
it looks like we'll be waiting for
another update before the halloween
store is truly here
hey that reminds me think the storm king
will return i do hope so
i have the pickaxe he fears the most
whoa we're missing something huge
hurt watch baby the hut which keeps on
giving continues to give
can you spot the difference this time
around well first the
truck is still waiting to be moved
around 20 weeks later
staff issues in fortnite the hut itself
though has a fresh lick of varnish to
all the wood
but the biggest update is on the floor
check this out that tiled floor goodness
complete with more cracks
than a nudist beach then the heartwatch
poi
slowly takes over the map and one day
i'm praying that this will be linked to
the story somehow
one day who's with me just me
yay
ooh speaking of storyline updates we had
a tiny update to the story of thor
his forever vanishing memory and the
entire marvel arch
galactus is now close enough to be
spotted in the sky
and recognized as the world eater i
couldn't get the camera any closer than
this sadly but i'm sure he'll be even
closer
next update and rest assured before the
final battle i'll recap the entire story
because sometimes it can feel as if
there is no story but there is
it's just hidden away we can find it the
other storyline we followed revolves
around the gnome population
led by our lord and savior graham the
gnome last month
we saw a mystery slurp juice salesman
arrive at the island
he gathered an audience and was
immediately blown up by his rival
we jumped into action to rescue the
other gnomes threatened with explosive
barrels
and then wiped out their propaganda
attempts too and finally we found the
man himself
in a basement where all weirdos live
where do you live
and this was another character i asked
you to name this was a landslide victory
you guys decided to call him
the nominator as he's half robot
terminator dude
and half gnome good choice i'm not sure
if it's nominator or denominator
so i'll just keep using both hope that's
okay with you the nominator is destined
to eradicate the island of gnomes
but this week he's gone missing no
longer in his secret lair
but around the world his presence is
still known over by the damn turbine is
a suspicious piece of artwork
a graffiti tag for the nominator made by
his robotic
minions are there more to be found what
could this mean
and where is the nominator by the way if
you do visit this spot in game you'll be
rewarded with
xp and a clue to the next step of the
story
most want it i guess we are tracking him
down now
let me know if you find him he must pay
for what he did
[Music]
before the major update today was a
series of smaller micro updates i wanted
to make sure we documented
the first of which is the addition of
rocket league to fortnite
in this weird and wonderful crossover
over at ferris bueller's house
you know the place with so many fallen
cranes it's hard to explain to someone
who doesn't play
fortnite yeah here you'll find a trophy
cabinet with in-game items
over the walls are posters and
downstairs in the bedroom
there's even more goodies to find i like
these smaller updates the small nods to
other things
here you can also find a unique vehicle
donned with rocket league info another
nice touch
and if you get close enough to the
trophy cabinet you'll hear the music
from the game
i know it's not a big deal but it's
worth the recognition gg mr or mrs epic
developer
oh damn i just assumed someone's gender
please don't cancel me internet
and the update i wanted to show you last
time but stark's poi was completely
messed up and i couldn't
you've already seen where i'm going with
this because the stark bus is in game
right now taking us into each and every
match but this
has been foreshadowed for weeks after
bringing up his own pri into the game
stark began upgrading the battle bus
first with simple blueprints
he then took his work into the garage a
small oil drop gave us the location
to keep an eye on and then the battle
bus began to change
last week it was completed in the garage
before it was updated and used in the
game a few days ago
this is the kind of series of updates
that really impresses me
look at all the steps to get to this
point crackshot's cabin becomes a barn
from iron man 2
which then is used to design
interdimensional travel which then
creates those beacons
which are then switched on which then
grow in power and bring us a new poi
stark then looks at the battle bus and
plans a change then
implements that change and then boom
he's ready
this is mind-blowing and what is his
next step just look in the sky
all these micro updates are preparing us
for battle with the eater of worlds your
mom
hi karen so so there we have it week 8
fortnight season 4. how did i do what
did i miss
please let me know in the comments like
usual i'll be in there stalking it's not
weird it's just how i spend my days
on screen now are people who i owe a
great thanks to
using my code even though my fortnite
content isn't regular enough right now
i'm going to try and fix that my
apologies
i really appreciate what you do for me
and i feel like i have my
enthusiasm back now and i have two more
videos planned over the next week
if i haven't replied to your twitter dm
yet i'm sure by now you know i will
it just takes me a while to get to
things thanks in advance for supporting
me
right i will do my best to get out of
your ear holes right now cheers for
sticking around till the end i'm adam
you're awesome
i'll see you next time
bye